all right everybody we are back with an
audience full of female sports ball fans
to celebrate
we are also joined by the stars of the
film total icons and legends Jane Fonda
Ford
so did any of you actually play sports
growing up you played sports right yeah
no I was a cheerleader I was a
cheerleader too yeah I'm sorry but where
I'm from cheerleaders are more athletic
than most people so that's a sport where
I'm from yeah well though I didn't
[Applause]
that women played when I went to school
well that oh good God in heaven
[Applause]
picture of me no though I didn't know
any women went out for sports that was
that was it that was the sport I knew of
was this before you were like Gidget or
anything that yes that was before yeah I
was in high school
I wasn't Gidget yet
but she lived inside
[Applause]
so you played with the softball I did
play some Backpage soft by pitched I was
the pitcher oh yeah
it's a boss position I owe you I well I
I couldn't see a better place for me on
the team just to be the star
that's right
athletic how many of you
the Jane Fonda workout videos
I I did it with Jane Fonda so did Sally
I did it with my mom I I actually I
actually used to her first
um workout place was in the valley and I
used to go that because I lived in the
valley and one day there she was
teaching the class it was like jaw
dropping and I was like working out
right behind her I luckily was in the
business then but just a very tiny
aspect of the business because I was
doing television and she was already I
attended her class too wow do you
remember that do you remember me no
I remember Sally I don't remember you
come back come back
she'll make it up to you
there you go here we go
remember
his hands you are memorable
just not for her Jane huh it's too late
[Applause]
I I would assume it's obviously the
comedian of the group that is probably
the funniest but I feel like you could
probably all hold your own with wit
right am I right who's like the funniest
woman you're going out here she's the
one that made me laugh the loudest okay
Sally is a very very funny she's like
bewildered you know what
I I don't think I didn't mean to be
funny I think I said good morning and
she bursts out laughing
Lily Lily makes me laugh yeah uh
obviously that was kind of my
my first yes how about the flirtiest
who's the flirtiest Rita
I I was going to say maybe either one of
you I was going to say one of you two no
I mean and honestly Rita knows I'm going
oh my god get the bag for this woman
like she's yeah
somebody give her the hook for goodness
sake no live your life can I tell you a
story about at 100 please good one day
oh no when Jane and I oh no
I can't wait I love you but shut up
so one day Jane and I are sitting in the
dark waiting for a scene to get lit and
it's just the two of us and Jane out of
the blue
says to me
um how do you feel about sex
and I immediately said oh God no I'm
done
and she said okay
so about a week later
we were all going to do a scene in the
locker room
and in the locker room are these amazing
amazing people the guys the guys in the
movie
and we all are starting to make we are
we're entering the room this is not part
of the this is not part of the scene
this is just we're entering the room and
to my absolute
um this is true absolutely I have to
stand up
[Applause]
Center Stage my absolute
amazement I swear to God
I swear to God to my absolute amazement
I take a deep breath and I go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and then I said to myself
[Applause]
I'm talking to myself and say oh my God
what's the matter with you you're 90 for
God's sake you're 90 you're alive and
you know I know now I know I know the
words to where live here there was a
little ovary saying everybody up
[Applause]
oh my God and it's true there must have
been because I mean once suddenly
attacked me
[Laughter]
oh my God I wish y'all could stay here
forever okay wait I I can only imagine
what this
um set was like it's amazing it was
finished the film it's amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
foreign